do as much you know jumping out of
helicopters kicking in terrorist doors
and shooting them in the face so you
were doing uh uh for lack of a better
thing you were disarming bombs
underwater mines that is part of the
role of the australian clearance divers
you're an australian clearance oh this
was during the military this year yeah
oh wow so why does that make a
difference it makes because he was a
braver he's it's braver than to just say
i'm going to grab her yeah that's a
brave thing first of all to be in the
military kudos god bless you and then to
do what you did and to have this
i thought you were just kind of i think
what about you talk about bravery what
about david dobrik just showing up on a
boat all his friends leave he stays with
the guy that's lost two limbs to dive
with sharks i think what's impressive is
he was defusing bombs so now he's like
now he's like my wife told me that
you're you were claustrophobic so just
scuba diving alone no i wasn't
claustrophobic my wife told me you were
never no he she said you're good she's
like yeah you told me you're because
she'd know better
maybe i was and i've just you know no
you're wrong you're very claustrophobic
so the fact that you would even
uh oh oh she's coming in what i've never
said
you're a liar i thought she said that
you were afraid to well okay no i was
terrified of sharks my two greatest
fears in the world before i got attacked
were sharks and public speaking
and now my whole job is as a shark
diving public speaker it's very odd can
i ask you this when you know you're
underwater right and you're wearing all
the apparatus for being underwater and
then the shark does this to you
uh the first thing i would do if that
happened to me is scream right how do
you scream underwater what a great
question i wasn't i was the worst
[ __ ] question i i wasn't actually
diving don't even stop that that's just
how do you scream underwater
it's the worst [ __ ] question in the
history of questions
it's a great question how do you scream
underwater
all right thank you for that
jesus christ kind of like that was it
[Applause]
paul was trying to kind of like that
paul my mouth was probably open while
doing it but i wasn't diving i was on
the surface i was pretending to be an
attack swimmer and the r d department of
the military were using this new
equipment testing it to see if they
could track attack swimmers coming in to
put bombs on our ships and so i was
pretending to be an attack swimmer i was
just on the surface wetsuit pair of fins
that's it and the shark came up from
underneath me in sydney harbour first
shark attack in sydney harbour right in
central i've been in sydney harbor yeah
yeah first shark attack in sydney harbor
in 60 years i knew it was sydney harbor
we're the same obviously
not the same person no no one's a harbor
and the other person oh oh one is a
right i knew the person thank you what
are you talking about i have no idea
anymore okay
paul you gotta explain how when you got
back on the boat your friend had to
oh yeah like there's some gruesome stuff
that went down right now you gotta give
those details some gruesome stuff that
went down that thing so i'm like
swimming back to the boat so the shark
grabs me takes me underwater uh starts
thrashing me around and i'm just
accepting the fact that i'm going to die
you really
absolutely yeah i i you know
life flashed before my eyes yours
literally when people started
what happened was
i realized i was gonna die and i
remember thinking to myself i'm not
going home today i'm gonna die right now
and the question came to me are you
ready to die
and i looked back you didn't have the
question like how how do i scream
underwater no i'd already done that i'd
already screamed and ran out of air and
this is where i'm like in agony getting
eaten and drowning at the same time and
so i look back on everything that i'd
done as a lost kid and then everything
i'd achieved in the army airborne and
then the navy clearance divers and all
of these amazing things that i'd
actually done with my life and i thought
you know what i have no regrets if i'm
going to die i'm ready to go wow
and i didn't what's the story that he
was saying to uh david what's the what
are you telling him to tell us what he's
got to say it's his story i can't i
can't start telling his story i'm so
dramatic i was losing so much blood i
swam back to the safety boat through a
pool of my own blood my one of my hands
gone my whole hamstring of my leg is
gone so i can't even feel my rudolph oh
my god the guys in the safety boat got
to me pulled me out of the water and to
stop the bleeding one of my teammates
had to stick his hand inside my leg and
pinch closed a slippery squirting artery
oh my god i remember one day when my
wife had her period i had to slip my no
it's not the same story
but i was stopping
[Music]
you